like many of you here at max tech we
love covering
all things tech and i in particular love
covering the latest headphones and
earbuds
from apple to sony to samsung
we have so much amazing technology at
our fingertips
but with that i found that i often take
it for granted
especially when cochlear america's
reached out and wanted a partner on a
video
about their amazing kanso 2 sound
processor at first
i was a little bit skeptical but after
looking into it
i was shocked by how much of a
difference this tech could make in
people's lives
and i knew that i had to cover it 466
million people worldwide
and almost 50 million americans are
affected by hearing loss
according to the world health
organization for those who have severe
hearing loss or even complete loss
and you'll see how it could change your
life cochlear keeps innovating and the
new cancer 2 sound processor
allows people to connect to a smartphone
and other devices and listen to music
take calls and more which i thought was
completely normal for everybody since i
do that daily
when in fact many people with hearing
loss can't do that at all
the kanto 2 also stands out because it's
wireless and it doesn't need an
additional module
behind the ear i got a chance to
virtually meet justin and ask him some
questions and see
what kind of an impact the kanso two has
made in his life
thank you justin uh for joining me and
being willing to share your story
my first question is um how was your
life before your cochlear
implant i actually grew up wearing
hearing aids
uh so i wore hearing aids from the time
i was about four or five
but i got my cook one point when i was
27.
during that time my hearing loss just
got progressively worse so the hearing
aids
had just become more and more powerful
to help me and then it
got to the point where even the hearing
aid wasn't helping me once i got the
cochlear implant
pretty amazing i guess i didn't realize
how much um
sound or access the sound i had lost i
haven't experienced
what you're talking about but for me
it's vision like my vision slowly
progressively just keeps getting worse
and i got contacts not too long ago and
when i popped those in
i was like shocked like i'm driving on
the roads that i usually drive home
and i've never noticed like mountains in
the background
or anything because it's so blurred out
it's a great analogy
i think you know contact lenses are a
good example of something where it's
just
blurry then all of a sudden so clear
again that's a good that's a good
example
with cochlear implants how bad the
hearing loss that you talked about how
bad that affect your life
uh i noticed myself kind of withdrawing
a little bit
uh going to social events it was really
hard to
kind of carry on a conversation i would
have to rely on my wife to kind of
let me know that somebody was asking
something or what they were saying so i
turned to her for support so it got it
got pretty hard
at work things were pretty tough i'm an
audiologist
i'm testing people who have hearing loss
and i was struggling even at work as
well
trying to do my job did it help being in
that field
kind of knowing what your what your
options are what you're choosing to do
make that choice easier
it was always in the back of my mind
that i probably knew i'd have to get a
cochlear implant eventually
um it also helped to kind of see so many
people get
them and do well with them so what was
your first sound processor
i know the different one now what was
the first features does it
have it's called the cochlear freedom it
was
a much bigger device it was
it was an on the ear processor so that
was that was great you know you don't
have to
have the the line or the string
connected to a box on your
on your belt or anything like that it
was a good processor
you know there were like push buttons on
the on the processor which was fairly
new there was a little screen on there
so you can see kind of which program you
were in and it did
did a good job it was it was quite heavy
um i do remember that
yeah when i was looking into what's kind
of available now in the
console 2 i didn't even know there was
the older ones with the wire and the
belt pack
yeah awesome living today to have all
these new capabilities
i've actually had almost
every single sound processor since that
one what was really a big deal
maybe two sound processors after freedom
was
there was some automaticity that was
starting to happen so
sound processor would actually monitor
the environment and then change the
program
based on the environment i was in the
hardware
like the microphone i think you'll kind
of appreciate this the microphone and
the processor got better
we cover a ton of all the new headphones
and stuff that comes out it's cool every
year
we're seeing this progression in quality
and background noise filtering and stuff
it's really awesome to see that tech
being pushed forward and
for me it's awesome to see now it's not
only in the latest gadgets that are
coming out but it's in
things like this where it actually
changes people's lives so how's it been
switching over to this one compared to
the previous ones there's definitely
um a difference in off the year this is
the first time where like i have nothing
on my ear
it's just free the other really cool
thing with the kansa 2
oh there's actually a few but um it's
completely wireless like you said so
uh it connects to my my cell phone so
right now i'm actually talking to you
through my cell phone
um there's no wires just like uh you
would like
um you know with wireless headphones uh
essentially
i just have that all built in um as part
of my device that helps me here
but i can also connect to my phone i can
stream
um you know video from my phone
listen uh you know watch netflix or i
can listen to a podcast
which i do while i'm riding my bike
doing some work and that kind of stuff
too
so i can talk hands-free in the car
there's just a lot that
that you can actually just not being
tethered to the phone having to put it
up to your ear you can
you can do quite a bit since i could do
all of this which is amazing all this
stuff is packed in this device
i have to ask how much did it cost how
expensive
was it and was it kind of since it's a
health device was that covered by
insurance or insurance does cover it so
it is a you know it is there's surgery
involved
um and insurance does cover it how
was that was it more difficult than you
expected to get it
the surgery and the recovery or was it
easier or
an outpatient surgery so you go into the
hospital in the morning and you're
typically done by the afternoon it took
a couple weeks for
kind of like the swelling over the side
to go down wait for that swung to go
down because there's a magnet under the
skin
and then there's a magnet and the sound
processor and that's how they connect so
would you mind showing me how it
connects
and how it looks on the side oh yeah
sure i'll
uh i'll turn my head here so you can
kind of if you can see the can though
you let me know but
uh essentially it sits right here um
and it i can just pull it off yeah and
as soon as it pops on magnetically you
can start hearing again
yeah the sound comes right on the other
thing between the kanso and the kanso
ii the original kanso is this is
rechargeable
so at night i literally just take the
whole thing off and drop it in a little
charging dock and it actually
wirelessly charges the device as well
those people that are out there that are
dealing with hearing loss
and they're on the fence of getting the
implants because involved surgery and
everything else
would you suggest for them to go with it
um
yeah without a doubt uh to be totally
honest i was
rolling into that operating room
wondering if i
if i was still doing the right thing um
i'd seen a lot of people
get a cochlear implant at in the clinic
and
saw the benefits of it but i can kind of
make do
um but then kind of coming out the other
side
getting activated starting to hear again
hearing
these soft soft sounds that i hadn't
heard in a long time being able to look
at somebody and not have to see their
lips
understand what they're saying being in
a noisy room and actually being able to
truly hear somebody and what they're
saying when they're not facing me or
something like that is
it's amazing i mean i i don't know where
i would be in life honestly
if i hadn't gotten a cochlear implant
it's made a huge difference for me
the technology and the advancements and
all those kind of things have just
made something great and good even
better
here's a little more info about this
amazing tech and how it works
as you can see this thing is small and
it is truly wireless which makes it very
convenient
not only that but it's also the only
cochlear implant that you can control
from your smartphone
i personally love being able to control
a ton of my smart home devices right
from my phone
so i'm glad that cochlear keeps
innovating and allowing those with
hearing loss
to stream content from their compatible
apple device directly to their implant
i never thought that there are so many
people that can't just pull out their
phone
and listen to music and take calls and
face time with their family
and with the cancer 2 sound processor
you can stream directly from your phone
and all of this is now possible you also
get a very handy smartphone app for
android users as well
and you can quickly customize and
control your kanso too
just like you can with airpods and other
headphones if you lose your device you
can use the find my processor feature to
help locate it and just like the latest
headphones and earbuds the kanso 2 can
cancel out background noise
with this dual microphones which can
really improve the audio quality
and you can focus on sound in front of
you and filter out what you don't want
for those looking to customize their
processor there's also multiple color
options available
we cover a ton of tech here at max tech
but this is the kind of stuff that can
not only make your life more enjoyable
but it can absolutely change your life
if you want to learn more about the
kanso 2 sound processor check out the
link in the video
description thank you guys for watching
and let us know what you think about
this kind of amazing tech
down in the comment section below click
that circle above if you
enjoyed this video and you want to
subscribe this has been max and i'll see
you
in the next video
[Music]
you